- Vous aurez du mal à trouveritg
dans les kiosques du marché
Jean-Talon.
- Bien, les prix sont un peu
exagérés. c'est 7 $.
- Le prix est exorbitant,
et les laitues, d'une qualité
discutable. Les maraîchers les
ve
SERGE MARTICOTTE, Corporation
des marchés publics de Montréal
- Les petits commerçants,
on n'en tient pas en stock
ou peu parce qu'elle est trop,,,
elle n'est pas là.
- Le consommateur ague
se tournera plutôt vers
des solutions de rechange,
comme les laitues d'
- C'était trop cher,
fait que je l'ai a a achetée,
j'ai acheté d'autre chose.
- Veux, veux pas, si onacacacacs
pourront pas la vendre
à ce prix-là. Ça se résume
en ça, il faut juste pasetetete.
- La cause de l'augmentation des
prix se trouve en Californie,
où la sécheresse a facilité
le développement l l l l l l l s
romaine et iceberg.
MICHEL LARRIVÉE, Hector Larrivée
fruits et légumes
- Alors,épépépépépépépépépépépé,
l'offre est très, très basse
sur les marchés. Il n'y a pas
de laitues à vendre.
-
et légumes payait habituellement
40 $ la caisse de 24 pommes
de laitues. Il débourse
maintenant entre 100 et 150 $
- Je suis dans l'industrie
depuis au-delà de 45 ans
J''ai jamais vu des prix tenir
aussi haut, aussi long
- C'est ce qu'il nous reste
pour la journée.
- C'est quoi, le problème
avec cette laitue-là?
c'est vraiment pas la même
qualité qu'on a généralement.
Elle est toute petite.
- Un véritable casse-tête
pour ce restaurant végétal l l e
depuis quelques semaines déjà.
SÉBASTIEN CHABOT,
gérant général, Aux Vivres
- Ce matin, jepapapapapapapapapt
pour me dire qu'il n'y en avait
juste pas du tout pour
la journée.
- Des chaînes de restauration
diminuer la verdure dans leurs
repas. Et les laitues pourraient
s'avérer être la pointe
de l'iceberg.
- On a subi des hausses
chou-fleur, le brocoli commence
à monter, les fntntntntnt monté.
- Sans compter les tomates
de la Californie, dont les prix
des sommets en raison
de la sesesesese.
Ici Jean-Philippe Hughe